[Music]
i really enjoy working with fishkin it's
something that feels right
because i spend so much time outside i'm
inspired by this huge landscape that
alaska has
i tend to gravitate towards those
materials that mimic the natural beauty
that i'm used to seeing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is joel isaac i am a denia
athabascan alaska native artist and i
work a lot with living materials like
fish skin or wood
for thousands of years people in alaska
have been fishing and only taking what
you need really is a traditional way of
working with fish
i use fish skin to create many different
types of objects
i've made high heels for models i've
made dresses i made a halibut skin
motorcycle jacket i make masks it's
stronger per thickness than mammal hide
and that gives it more strength for
stretching and pulling
it does expand and contract and you can
have kind of a relationship with it
most the fish skin that i use i catch
and all the fish can i use i clean and i
process and i tan myself
one of the traditional methods is with
fish eggs and that takes three days of
soaking the fish skins and then they
need to be hand softened which is a very
laborous process
the land has been very formative for the
type of work that i create and fishkin
for me is a very sustainable practice
it's a living material and i have a
connection to it
it's been part of my whole entire life
being here at the beach that's part of
what makes me denia is that interaction
living with salmon and being around the
land
[Music]
[Music]
you